hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fun see here's the
rules you must use the food given you
can only add to the food you can buy
whatever ingredients you wish let's see
what's inside
drumrolls jello I've never had a jello
before I've heard of jello shot I've
never had a Jetta even though I use
alcohol for my cooking all the time it
seems like it takes more than four hours
to set so I'm glad we don't have time
limit this time in general I don't like
official color in my food artificial
raspberry flavor is a little bit of
pudding for me so I want to add
something fancy I got a few ideas it
could be tricky but I'm excited to make
it fancy here it's what I got heavy
cream graham crackers rolls water
raspberries
cream cheese butter sour cream and lemon
from the pantry I got four near I
extract powdered sugar granulated sugar
gelatin and water all right let's get
started make it fancy so first I'm going
to melt butter 5 tbsp so usually butter
has this measurement on a wrapping paper
talks to the person who invented this my
lady eats at the spa well if you're
making pastry you don't need to use
knife that much
that's my excuse ok I'm gonna go to
microwave and just melt this completely
right so butter is melted I'm going to
process graham cracker in a food
processor so if you don't have food
processor at home you can film cracker
in a ziplock bag and you can just pound
it with rolling pin I have 9 graham
crackers
you just want to grind until very fine
the transfer this into a ball combine
with melted butter mix until well
combined I'm going to put graham cracker
mixture into the springform pan just
pressing down this graham cracker
mixture okay
now I'm going to show this in the
refrigerator next step I'm going to whip
heavy cream use one and a quarter cup
whipped cream by hand so I can control
the softness I want to go for you gain
muscles and you can get the result it
looks good it's stiff peak I'm going to
put in a refrigerator so jello has
gelatin but I couldn't figure out how
much gelatin it's in a jello box so I'm
going to use gelatine to make sure
stabilize it's one tablespoon and three
tablespoons of cold water and leave it
for like five to six minutes and while
we are waiting mix cream cheese 24 ounce
cream cheese room temperature and a half
cup of sugar if you don't have a
electric mixer just use regular whisk
the cream cheese looks good so I'm
adding two tablespoon of powdered sugar
quarter cup of sour cream and this is
also room temperature so they mix well
and two teaspoons of lemon juice and one
teaspoon of vanilla so just mix
everything well together and now I'm
going to add a tablespoon of heavy cream
right now it's very stiff so I'm going
to hit any microwave so this is nice and
melted so if you see like lungs don't
you start strainer into the cream cheese
mix and mix well combined
whip cream into this cream cheese
mixture it's look like well incorporated
jello time Wow punjah very strong
artificial smell a tablespoon I have no
idea how much sugar and how much gelatin
and after shell powder in it so we have
to just slow it 1 tbsp of rose water
personally I love floral flavor 2 tbsp
of regular water super red almost look
like a blood
I like roll tie rods very combination I
think it works pretty well
you're too much world's water sometimes
there's our taste like soap but if you
can kind of balance it out I feel like
floral flavor and Azure is very nice and
fancy I'm going to divide this cream
cheese mixture into 5 different portions
quarter cup and half cup and one cup and
one and quarter cup and leftover but
we're going I'm adding 1 teaspoon 2 and
1/2 teaspoon and then I'm adding 3 and
lastly 70 spoon of raspberry jello
mixture and then we're gonna mix it so
I'm adding different amounts because I
want to make a different shade of pink
so I feel like this dessert is a lot of
steps it's not easy to be fancy ok so I
go full shade of pink and white base so
now I'm going to put each cream-cheese
mixture into different piping bags and
after you put in a piping bag use your
hand and kind of squeeze so it doesn't
have air bubble and I'm gonna go get my
cake awaits the ground crust
I'm gonna pipe the base mixture starting
with the outer edge I'm piping lighter
color in outside and piping darker color
to the inside
and I'm going to read with spatula so
what you want to do is make a gradation
of different pink almost look like a
ripple and it's almost looked like a
boob repour nipple and make sure lean
the side of the pan before you put in a
refrigerator so next I'm going to make
raspberry sauce the one pint of
raspberry which is like 200 grams and 50
grams of sugar and 1/2 lemon squeezing
over mesh sieve so the sieve doesn't get
into it and you heat it up until
raspberry dissolves
okay so raspberry is dissolved and
associate stick so it's ready I'm going
to strain it because it's a lot of seeds
you kind of want to have smooth sauce
instead of chunky sauce Oh in a
refrigerator so I can stop with the
design okay so the cake has to chill
overnight I hope it's as well and we
will see it tomorrow
okay so this is chilled overnight I hope
this is set and let's take out the mold
I am running off the spatula along the
cake nice it's that which is good when
you're cutting the cake if you dip in
the hot water it helps cause gelatine
it's become a little bit loose nice look
at all these colors so raspberry sauce
youth drops
let me get chopsticks it's kind of look
like heart that's cute and I'm done
[Music]
it's really bad I think I made of jello
fancy welcome Kevin faux make you fancy
episode oh thank you for having me I'm
very excited can you guess what it is
and what I made fun see so it looks like
a cheesecake but it looks like kind of
like a cherry cheesecake it's like very
red so I would almost say maybe it's
like kool-aid did you use do you want to
go one more so it's it's close to cool
or is it jealous oh my god okay all
right
oh really good it does have kind of like
that little bit of like squishiness from
the jello Wow
great work did I make jello a fancy you
made jello real fancy make it fancy well
I'm very happy to be here I've heard
you've been calling me out and
mentioning me in some of your recent
episodes
I miss you I'll be make it big for me so
season two I'm gonna challenge you to
make me a giant mushroom I think about
it mmm oh good guess what I made fun see
raspberry jam I made this cake with
jello oh nice thank you make sense cuz
they're no big cheesecake no makers name
yeah
I got thumbs up well looks like there's
only one last thing left to do yes make
it fancy thank you for watching I hope
you make it home if you do please tag me
on Instagram and don't forget to us make
it fancy
[Music]